hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the history of the
magical sporting event known far and
wide Around The Wizarding World as
quidditch intro and definition of
quidditch the Quidditch is without a
doubt the most popular and well-known
sport played by witches and wizards in
the entirety of The Wizarding World it
is as you may have guessed or probably
already know extremely magical in nature
as the whole game revolves around
various bulls that fly about of their
own volition and is played while riding
around on broomsticks with two opposing
teams of seven quidditch has played on a
pitch typically set up on a deserted
Moor or field far from the view of us
Muggles and just as with many of our
non-magical team sports there are
different positions on each team these
positions are known as the chasers of
which there are three the beaters of
which there are two a single keeper and
a Seeker Greenwich is also played using
four different balls an entirely
seamless red leather quaffle 12 inches
in size and used to score points and
opposing teams goals two 10-inch iron
bludgees which only serve to knock
players off their broomsticks and their
game and a golden snitch a small Golden
Ball with silver rotational Wings both
teams then have three goal posts raised
high in the air with a large hoop at the
top of each it's the chaser's job to use
the quaffle to score on the opposing
team's goals each successful shot
through one of these hoop goals is worth
10 points goal posts are guarded by
teams keeper similar to that of a muggle
Sports team's goalie the beta's primary
responsibility is to hit or beat the
bludge is away from their teammates in
order to allow them to score points
uninterrupted without being knocked off
of their broomsticks and then there's
the Seeker who basically plays a game
all on their own with their one and only
goal to find and catch the golden snitch
before the other team's Seeker doing so
earns the Seekers team 150 points and
signifies the end of the match of course
as with any sport quidditch hasn't
always been played this way it has
evolved over the centuries and has a
rich and rather colorful past in fact we
are fortunate enough to have an
incredibly robust account of quidditch's
History thanks to quidditch Through the
Ages a text by the wizard kenilworthy
wisp throughout the remainder of today's
video the information I'll be sharing is
based on kennelworthy's tremendous
research and body of work all of which
focused on the evolution and history of
this incredible sport
the use of broomsticks for flying before
that was quidditch or any game that used
broomsticks for that matter there had to
be the invention of brooms for flight
taking place many many centuries ago
this revolutionary way of transportation
for the Wizarding World is said to have
begun as early as
ad962 when witches and wizards went
looking for ways to fly unencumbered by
the laws of gravity after all they could
make objects float about and fly around
so why not people why not broomsticks
and so the witches and wizards of the
time got to work and invented a way to
make brooms fly with people balanced on
top of them
it likely goes without saying that these
broomsticks were very much unlike the
brooms of today and are known to have
been incredibly uncomfortable to fly on
with plenty of knots and splinters
sticking up along the handle
the Museum of quidditch which is located
in London has a medieval broomstick on
display which showcases just how
rudimentary these initial modes of
transportation were it is made of
unvarnished Ash and the end is simply
Hazel Twigs haphazardly bound together
of course none of this is much of a
surprise due to the time in history and
a general lack of industrialized
Manufacturing in fact it's said that the
individual families would actually make
their own broomstick leading to each
broom being incredibly unique and
varying greatly from one another
the use of brooms for entertainment by
the 10th Century however the practice of
flying broomsticks had come a long way
and witches and wizards across the globe
were using them for entertainment
purposes rather than just travel one of
the first known events in which brooms
were used for sport and entertainment
was a well-known annual Swedish
broomstick race that ran over 300 miles
from copperberg to Arya plug directly
through a dragon reservation also played
as early as 1100s was the ancient German
game of stitchdock depictions of Stitch
stock can be seen in the 1105 painting
of Gunther the violent is the winner
which suggested a poll of maybe 20 feet
or so was topped with an inflated Dragon
bladder protected by one team on regular
brooms who were tied to the pole with a
rope about half the length of the pole
the opposing team would then attempt to
puncture the bladder using specifically
sharpened broomsticks around the same
time there was also an Irish game called
I'm gonna butcher this einkengan in
which players would carry a ball made of
the gallbladder of a goat called the Dom
fly through a row of burning barrels set
up on stilts and attempt to throw the
Dom through the last Barrel without
Catching Fire whichever player could
complete this task the fastest one and
while that may sound like one of the
most dangerous sports one could
participate in ongen gain was nothing
compared to I'm gonna butcher this one
as well creation a Scottish game that is
considered to be the most dangerous
ancient broom sport popular throughout
the Middle Ages before it was finally
made illegal in 1762 the game had
players wearing cauldrons on their heads
as they tried to catch as many Falling
Rocks as they could without dying the
Rocks used for the sport were typically
Charmed Boulders that become raining
down from a height of at least 100 feet
the following 11th century Gaelic poem
describes the danger
the players assembled 12 fine hearty men
they strapped on their cauldrons stood
poised to fly at the sound of the horn
they were swiftly Airborne but 10 of
their number were fated to die
the broomstick sports that followed were
incredibly mellow in comparison to
Creation with very few being of nodes a
few standouts however include the
English game known as shunt bumps which
was essentially jousting on broomsticks
and swivenhodge which was similar to
muggle tennis with the exception of it
being played on broomsticks in the case
of swiffenhage players would sit
backwards on their brooms and hit an
inflated Pig's bladder back and forth
using the brush end of their Broomsticks
much later in the 18th century an
American game called quadpot was
invented by Abraham peasgood a wizard
who unintentionally altered the game of
quidditch when he was attempting to
bring the game to the United States but
I'm getting ahead of myself for we have
yet to cover the beginnings of the very
game we're discussing here in today's
video which brings us to the beginnings
of quidditch quidditch was likely
invented in 11th century around the same
time as many of the other European broom
sports that we've just discussed the
first known sightings of quidditch was
by which who lived in queerdich Marsh in
the 1000s called Gertie Kettle Gertie
recorded being rather bothered by a
nearby broomstick game in her diary
describing what is believed to have been
a primitive form of quidditch including
a rudimentary quaffle bludgers and gulls
the next account of the game didn't come
for another hundred years when a
Yorkshire wizard named Goodwin Neen
described the game in a letter he wrote
to his Norwegian cousin Goodwin's
description of quidditch signifies
several key things one is location in
Yorkshire suggested 100 years after
Gertie first saw the game being played
in quidditch Marsh quidditch had spread
across England and two the equipment and
game itself had evolved as Goodwin calls
the game itself quidditch with a K and
also used the terms bladder and catcher
which can presumably be forms of the
modern day bludger and Chaser in his
letter Goodwin also makes note of new
scoring barrels and describes there
being three at each end of the field all
of which were up on stilts from later
accounts given by various sources we
know that by the 1200s quidditch had
continued to evolve with new terminology
in addition to the game cropping up like
quaffle keepers gold baskets and
quadrich with a C
one of the biggest changes to the game
however didn't take place until the
middle of the 13th century when the
golden snitch was eventually added to
the game
yet before the small Bewitched Golden
Ball became an integral part of
quidditch there was a brief moment in
history in which live birds called
snidgets were used instead of the snitch
this rather barbaric practice was
inspired by snidget hunting which was a
popular Pastime in the early 1100s
hunting with a rather difficult
Endeavor and involved witches and
wizards searching for this species by
Broome the difficulty of the activity
was due to the birds themselves being
rather small and agile similarly to the
Quidditch snitch the snidget is golden
in color and looks like a puffed up ball
with wings the first time this ninja was
used in the game of quidditch was in
1269 when barbarous Bragg the chief of
the Wizards council at the time attended
a game in Kent and released one of these
birds onto the pitch
for whatever reason he then told the
Quidditch teams that he would give 150
galleons to the player who caught the
snidget first this random decision made
by barbarous led to snidget it's being
released during every Quidditch game
thereafter
the rules of the game were then altered
to include a hunter who pursued the
snidget with their one and only goal
being to catch and kill the bird in
order to end the game and earn their
team an additional 150 points as midgets
were kept on the pitch by repelling
spells cast by the crowd as they watched
the match fortunately for this
these birds became a protected species
by the mid-1300s when the new chief of
the Wizards Council Alfred de clagg
outlawed the use of snidgets in
quidditch matches in response to the
removal of the live birds from the game
a wizard from godric's Hollow Bowman
Wright invented the golden snitch a
skilled metal charmer Bowman modeled the
walnut-sized ball after the snidget
birds including their unique rotational
wings and bewitched it to stay within
the boundaries of the pitch
around the same time in 1362 the Wizards
Council decided to prohibit the playing
of quidditch within 50 miles of any
muggle town or settlement because of a
number of sightings of witches and
wizards flying around on their
Broomsticks
due to a general lack of cooperation
this decree was then amended to 100
miles in 1368. the birth of modern day
quidditch in 1398 zechariah's mumps was
the first wizard to write down and
record the rules of the game of
Quidditch
these rules also included instructions
on how and where witches and wizards
should play the game emphasizing the
need for caution around Muggles
one of zacharias's primary
recommendations was for those interested
in playing quidditch to set up that game
far away from any muggle habitants he
also advised that people play only at
night clearly zacharias's warnings were
not heeded as in 1419 the Wizards
Council made another decree that
quidditch should not be played and I
quote anywhere near any place where
there is the slightest chance that a
muggle might be watching or we'll see
how well you can play whilst chained to
a dungeon wall
despite the council's warnings however
adequate anti-mocal security measures
were not enforced until the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy went into effect several hundred
years later in 1692 it was at this time
that Britain created the department of
magical games and sports within the
British Ministry of magic a department
tasked with upholding the statute during
Wizarding sporting events during the
late 14th century and into the 15th the
game of quidditch itself continued to
evolve it was noted around this time in
the game's history that the pitch was
oval in shape and approximately 500 feet
long by 180 feet wide
the center of the pitch at a small
circle for releasing the balls at the
start of each match and at this time the
bludgers were made of carved stone
similar to modern day quidditch each
side had seven players and there was a
quiet judge or referee minding the game
during these formative years Keepers
played both goalkeeper and offensive
positions meaning that they could move
about the pitch and attempt to score on
the opposing team's goals if they wanted
to the first ever quidditch World Cup
was held in 1473 and has been held every
four years since then despite being
called the World Cup only European teams
participated for the first couple
hundred years with the first
non-european team joining the tournament
in the 17th century a list of 700 known
quidditch files can be found in the
record of the Department of magical
games and sports all of which occurred
during the final match of the inaugural
World Cup in 1473 between Transylvania
and Flanders
the evolution of modern day quidditch as
the centuries went by quidditch
continued to evolve into the game we
know and love today in 1538 a ban on
using ones against the opposing team
went into effect around that same time
due to the magically reinforced bats
used by the majority of betas bludgers
were no longer Made of Stone but lead
which eventually became Iron
by the early 1600s designated scoring
areas had been added to the pitch which
we know from the book The Noble sport of
warlocks written by quintius umphraville
in 1620 gwentius's work also indicates
that the scoring baskets had become
smaller than they were in the 14th
century and with the introduction of the
new designated scoring areas Keepers
were advised to play more like
traditional goalkeepers and no longer
attempt offensive Maneuvers in 1652 the
European Cup was established and has
been held every three years since then
the later half of the 1600s didn't see
much development in the game in fact it
was not until 1711 that a noteworthy
change occurred this was the year that
due to poor weather conditions the
quaffle officially became Scarlet in
color the bright red color was chosen in
an effort to help the players keep track
of the quaffle when it would fall from
play into the ground which had turned
incredibly muddy from the vast
quantities of rain it's like likely
rainy games like this that also led to
the bewitching of the quaffle to fall
slowly to the ground if dropped by a
player an innovation suggested by which
named Daisy penafold the rules recorded
by Zacharias mumps in 1398 but then
updated and made official by the
department of magical games and sports
upon its establishment in 1750. they are
as follows 1. though there is no limit
imposed in the height to which a player
may rise during the game he or she must
not stray over the boundary lines of the
pitch should a player fly of the
boundary his or her team must surrender
the quaffle to the opposing team
2. the captain of a team may call Four
timeouts by signaling to the referee
this is the only time players feet are
allowed to touch the ground during a
match
timeout may be extended to a two-hour
period if a game has lasted more than 12
hours failure to return to the pitch
after 2 hours leads to the team's
disqualification
3. the referee May award penalties
against the team the Chaser taking the
penalty will fly from the central circle
towards the scoring area all players
other than the opposing keeper must keep
well back while the penalty is taken
4. the quaffle may be taken from another
player's grasp but under no
circumstances must one player seize hold
of any part of another player's Anatomy
5. in the case of injury no
substitutions of plans will take place
the team will play on without the
injured player
6. ones may be taken onto the pitch but
must under no circumstances whatsoever
be used against opposing team members
any opposing team members broom the
referee any of the bulls or any member
of the crowd 7. a game of quidditch ends
only when the golden snitch has been
caught or by Mutual consent of the two
team captains with the general rules and
regulations well established by the 18th
century the next evolution in the game
focused on the player's primary piece of
equipment their broomsticks in the early
19th century players were using day
brooms and would place the cushioning
charm invented by Elliot smethwick in
1820 on their broomsticks in order to
make them more comfortable to ride 1901
saw the first ever Moon trimmer broom
created by Gladys boothby which was in
high demand for quidditch players for
quite some time however the moon trimmer
was eventually replaced in popularity by
the Silver Arrow which was the first
ever other true racing room reaching up
to 70 miles per hour in speed in 1926
the clean sweep broom company was
founded by Bob Bill and Barnaby ollerton
forming the first company to
mass-produce Quality Broomsticks
the clean sweep broom company marketed
their equipment as a racing broom
specifically designed for sporting use
the establishment of quite a few
broomstick companies followed soon after
including the comet Trading Company in
1929 ellerbean spudmore in 1940 and
Universal brooms Limited in 1955. a
major change up in the industry then
occurred when the Nimbus racing broom
company was launched in 1967. the
company simultaneously released their
first broomstick model that year the
Nimbus 1000 which could reach speeds of
up to 100 miles per hour and turn 360
Degrees throughout the evolution of the
Quidditch broomstick there were also a
few changes that took place which
affected how the game itself was played
for example in 1883 scoring baskets were
replaced with the hooped goal posts used
in modern day quignage this marked the
last major alteration to the pitch to
have occurred to this day then in 1884
the department of magical games and
sports announced a new rule known as the
stooging penalty which only allowed the
Chaser character in the quaffle to enter
the designated scoring area or a goal
would be disallowed then 1875 saw the
discovery of gripping charms which were
placed directly on quaffles eliminating
the need for them to have leather
handles or finger holes as they once did
the longest quidditch match in history
took place in 1884 when a game went on
for six months on bodmin Moore the
length of the match was due to both
Seekers failing to capture the golden
snitch after six long months both teams
finally gave up and mutually decided to
cool the game professional quiltich
leagues blade recreationally and at the
school age level quidditch is a game for
everyone however as with most popular
muggle Sports there are also a number of
professional leagues that participate in
matches year-round many of which are
attended by quidditch fans from all over
the world as Britain is the birthplace
of quidditch it truly comes as no
surprise that there are many
professional teams throughout Britain
and Ireland 13 to be exact they are the
Appleby arrows a northern english team
founded in 1612 the Bali Castle bats a
northern Irish team has won the
Quidditch League 27 times the carefully
catapults A Welch team founded in 1402
the chuddly cannons famous for having
won the Quidditch League 21 times but
Infamous for not having done so since
1892 the Falmouth Falcons a rough team
with a reputation for hard play the
holyhead harpies a female only Welsh
team founded in 1203 the Kenmare
castrols an Irish team founded in 1291
the Montrose magpies the most successful
team in the British and Irish League
having won 32 times they've also claimed
the European Championship twice the
pride of poetry a team from the Isle of
Skye founded in 1292 the puddle mayor
United the oldest team in the league
founded in 1163 the touch shell
tornadoes a team founded in 1520 The
wigtown Wanderers a team founded by
seven siblings in 1422 and the wimborne
Wasps a team founded in 1312. other
reputable teams in Europe include the
Bulgarian vratza vultures the French
guibran quaffle punches and the
Portuguese Braga broom Fleet worldwide
there are also many other teams
including the New Zealand muso Hora
macaws the Ugandan patonga proud sticks
and the Canadian Stonewall stormers and
with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think what
did I miss please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel who or
what should I cover the history of next
also be sure to check out the content on
Spotify as well as extra content on my
second Channel Harry Potter Theory extra
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]